[Musique]
[Musique] mon
pote
[Musique]
quand j'ai entendu la mort d'alfond khan euh j'ai
juste aimé que ce soit une période de confinement mais
je suis quand même venu dans cet hôpital
pour voir sa dernière je voulais juste
voir sa dernière réclamation c'était très choquant
je veux dire toi  souffraient depuis un certain
temps,
euh, mais nous espérions qu'il se
rétablirait et que nous pourrions le voir davantage
à l'écran,
donc c'était vraiment choquant comme
quelque chose
qui s'ajoute déjà à la triste chose
avec la pandémie qui se passe
bonjour
ça a sévèrement touché
euh tu sais y compris les salariés journaliers
ainsi que les techniciens ainsi que les
artistes donc
ça a causé de sérieux dégâts en fait
donc ça pourrait prendre encore deux à trois
ans pour se remettre complètement
[Musique]
très envie de retourner à  les cinémas
mais tout être humain craint aussi pour sa
vie
et comme les cas de virus
n'ont pas vraiment diminué à un niveau tel
que les gens se sentent en sécurité il y a de
l'hésitation il y a de l'
appréhension il y a de l'anxiété
[Musique]
donc
en tant que  chaîne d'expositions théâtrales euh vous
savez que nous n'étions pas très heureux à ce sujet
parce que nous pensons que
dans toute cette industrie, nous nous sommes tenus au
coude à coude pendant 100 ans,
donc tout ce que nous leur demandions de faire, c'est de
tenir bon
et de libérer leur  le contenu dans
les salles et ensuite publier
le contenu dans l'
industrie du cinéma ott sera pour toujours, il
n'y a donc pas d'alternative pour le cinéma
car lorsque la télévision a été introduite il y a
40 50 ans,
même les mêmes mots sont venus à cette
époque
et donc je pense que le  le pouvoir du cinéma
restera pour toujours